one of the anonymous accusers in our
Kelly's criminal cases speaking out
publicly for the very first time only on
CBS this morning lenita Carter describes
the alleged 2003 assault that helped
lead to the singer's arrest back in
February
Kelly as you know has pleaded not guilty
to ten counts of aggravated criminal
sexual abuse involving four alleged
victims
Jericka Duncan spoke with Carter earlier
this week and joins us at the table good
morning good morning lenita Carter is
the woman identified in the indictment
as LC R Kelly's hairdresser she was 24
years old at the time of the alleged
sexual assault we want to warn you some
of the details she reveals are very
disturbing I'm not ashamed of my past
anymore I'm not ashamed of what they say
or say lenita Carter says she braided
our Kelly's hair for more than a year
but saw him as more than just a client
she also considered him like an older
brother she even stood up for the singer
when he was arrested on child
pornography charges in 2002 so words
perfect didn't I would tell people pray
for him pray for him I do his hair he is
nothing like what they say he had never
propositioned you or asked you to do
anything sexual before but then this
particular day
what happened February 18 2003 I get a
phone call to come down and do his hair
when he came to the room and he asked me
for that head massage and I told him I
didn't do massages I laughed it off and
I didn't know he was for real if I could
change that there I wouldn't be in there
he pulled my my my break down by him and
he say suck it for daddy
sucking for daddy and I said no and I
did like this and he just started going
he knew like six six times Carter says
Kelly stopped only after someone knocked
on the door he didn't open the door
right away
he says fix your face fix
I knew that'll be my last day they're
not getting the bathroom I grabbed a
wall and it was a rose-colored towel now
wipe my face I'm not dressed no type of
way I look at myself in the mirror I
don't I'm not a beauty queen
I didn't perceive myself to be nothing
more than just hair braider and I was
thinking to myself like why it has
happened to me you called the police the
day that this happened the exact day
they asked for my clothing and I gave
them my favorite Tommy Hilfiger shirt
and that's where they found DNA evidence
DNA evidence for Mark Kelly on your
shirt it's a man at the time charges
were not filed in Carter's case
janaballah Kerr who was then the lead
sex crimes prosecutor has not responded
to our multiple requests for comment
celebrities are powerful celebrities
have support systems I have no support
system outside of my immediate family
ten months after the incident Carter
signed a $650,000 settlement and which
Kelly denied any wrongdoing and Carter
agreed to keep quiet
[Music]
in 2009 Kelly released a song about
having sex with a woman who braids his
hair that was one of the hairstyles that
I was known for doing that I never did
on him we were on the l-shaped couch
when the incident happened that song led
to another confidential settlement this
time for $100,000 Kelly again denied any
wrongful conduct but agreed to never
perform the song or included in future
albums
in January following the uproar sparked
by the lifetime document
arter responded to a plea by the current
Cook County State Attorney Kimberly Fox
for victims to call her office we need
actual witnesses and victims to have the
courage to tell their stories I'll be
going on my day you turn on the news
here's another our Kelly victim another
our Kelly victim another our Kelly V and
you just you just want to be there for
them did you see the interview that our
Kelly did with Gayle King in which he
denied ever sexually assaulting a woman
ever sexually assaulting anyone underage
yes what did you think when you were
watching that felt like it should be a
crime to publicly tell the story that he
able to get on television your life did
seeing that interview embolden you to
want to speak even more yes it's
actually the reason that I'm here
Kelly's defense attorney Steve Greenberg
told CBS this morning these allegations
were fully investigated by the police
and prosecutors and a decision was made
after evaluating all of the evidence not
to bring any charges I know that I love
myself today I know that I don't care
what anybody say about me do you feel
like this is a moment for you where you
get to tell your truth and people will
listen this is a release I've been
carrying this since 2003 I don't want to
be in a public but this isn't my life if
that's hard I know that I told the truth
we interviewed Carter the day after her
attorney Michael avenatti was charged
with embezzlement extortion and other
federal crimes he continues to represent
her the Cook County State's Attorney
declined to speak about Carter's claims
citing department policy against
commenting on open cases you can't help
but notice how she she knows the exact
date
tells and she's been through a lot I
mean not just with our Kelly allegedly
of course she said there's so much more
that she wants to talk about that she
hopes she'll be able to talk about when
there's a trial Jirga as you said it was
disturbing it was actually
stomach-turning to hear the details
spitting all of it was just very
disturbing but you also send the piece
that she signed an agreement not to
speak how is she able to speak now she's
just disregarding that she's
disregarding that agreement and again
it's a process for her she heard the
call from the state attorney yeah she
saw the interview that you did with our
Kelly and she said you know what he gets
to talk about what he says it's his
truth I'm gonna speak out yeah a lot of
people are glad she's telling her truth
too
and you hear one thing time and time
again from these victims when so many of
them questioned what did I do wrong I
was aggressive certainly if I'm not a
beauty queen you could sense the pain
that chart goes out to her you do wonder
why charges were not brought yeah thank
you thank you
you